Thai voters heading into the polling
Booth early on Sunday morning it's an
election that some say could be the most
important in decades
as he registered his vote the current
prime minister urged ties to do their
Democratic Duty
I would like to invite people all over
the country all ages and gender who are
eligible to cast their vote I want as
many people as they can to come out the
prime ministerial candidate from the
main opposition party per Thai looked
calm as she came to vote but was she
feeling optimistic yes of course I
a very good mood actually so yes I'm
excited but as she cast her ballot
she'll be very aware that election
results here are really simple her party
is already under investigation by the
election commission I don't have any
concert I just um I'm I'm just cheering
for for Thailand to for the people to
just come out and you know use their
rights that's all I wanted for now
the deciding factor could be moved
forward whose party leader was also
hoping for a high turnout their message
of Reform could take more support from
the military-backed parties or split the
opposition vote
it's the day Drew to a close so did the
polling stations under the watch for
live election monitors officials started
to call out the count in Bangkok it was
clear that move forward had made
significant gains achieving a clean
sweep of seats in the capital
but at the party headquarters none of
the Jubilation of an outright win
at least there's only two parties that
have passed the 100
milestones and the incumbent did not
manage to to pass that at all so I think
the
probability of minority government is
almost zero now a per Thai HQ a
significant change of mood too
the two opposition parties almost neck
and neck neither with a clear Victory
smile
Smiles announced a landslide after this
election nonetheless what is clear from
this election result is the entire
lecture has chosen to say no to the
military government it's ruled it for so
many years Tony Chang Al Jazeera thank
God